Так виглядає німецький паспорт вакцинації. Сюди заносять усі зроблені щеплення для попередження різних хвороб.
Сімейний лікар регулярно зазирає сюди, аби перевірити, чи всі щеплення ще дійсні.
Ще донедавна обов’язкової вакцинації у Німеччині не було.
Але рівно рік тому, з 1 березня 2020-го, набув чинності закон про обов’язкове щеплення від кору.
Щоб віддати дитину в дитсадок, приватні ясла чи до школи, батьки мають надати довідку про щеплення від кору
або про те, що дитина перехворіла і має імунітет.
Якщо ж батьки відмовляються вакцинувати своїх дітей, штраф може сягнути 2500 євро.
Щеплення від кору обов'язкове і для приватних нянь, співробітників дитсадків, шкіл, медичних установ
та громадських установ на зразок притулків для біженців.
У Німеччині частка населення, вакцинована від кору, 2013-го року була 97 відсотків,
а згодом скоротилася і становила рік тому 92-93 відсотки.
За даними ВООЗ, не можна говорити про повний захист населення, якщо вакциновано менше 95 відсотків.
Щодо інших хвороб німці самі вирішують після консультацій з лікарем, робити укол чи ні. Примусити нікого не можуть.
Рекомендації, які щеплення робити, кому і коли, розробляє Постійна комісія щодо щеплень, скорочено STIKO, при Інституті Роберта Коха.
Саме цей поважний орган щороку оновлює ось такий календар щеплень.
При чому різними мовами. Тут вказано, які щеплення і в якому віці варто робити. Загалом 14 базових щеплень.
Першу вакцинацію, це базова імунізація від ротавірусів, дитині рекомендують проводити у віці від 6 тижнів,
потім з інтервалом у місяць роблять другу і третю дозу.
Крім того, маленьких дітей у Німеччині щеплюють також від правця, дифтерії, коклюшу, поліомієліту, гепатиту В, краснухи та вітрянки.
Для дітей до 16 років потрібна згода батьків на проведення щеплення.
Після цього віку вони самі можуть вирішувати.
Дорослим оновлюють щеплення, приміром, від правця та дифтерії кожні 10 років.
А після 60 років роблять також щеплення від пневмокока та оперізуючого герпесу.
Вартість усіх базових щеплень покривають каси медичного страхування.
Лише за щеплення для подорожей, приміром, в Африку доведеться заплатити самому,
а за щеплення, необхідні для роботи, - роботодавцю.
При цьому в Німеччині є й чимало противників вакцинації. Причини - недовіра, страх та різноманітні теорії змови.
Приміром, ще до пандемії у 2019 році, за даними соцопитувань, лише 35 відсотків літніх німців зробили щеплення від грипу,
тоді як у Південній Кореї - 85%, а у Великобританії - 72% людей похилого віку.
Крім того, скороченню частки вакцинованого населення у Німеччині, з одного боку, сприяє
міграція з країн із нижчими ніж у Німеччині стандартами охорони здоров'я.
З іншого - скорочення вакцинації народжених останніми роками дітей.
Причому в більшості цих випадків причина не в неуважності батьків, які забули вчасно вакцинувати дитину,
а в ідеологічній упертості та екологічному стилі життя.
Відмова від атомної енергетики, хлорованої курятини, трансгенних рослин, полікарбонату та ультрапастеризованого молока -
це один бік екостилю життя, а опір вакцинації - інший.
Тим не менше, середня тривалість життя у ФРН продовжує зростати.
За даними німецького уряду, за останні 100 років вона зросла аж на 40 років.
І обумовлено це трьома факторами: чистою питною водою, збільшенням рівня гігієни та - проведенням щеплень.